welcome back to peers welcome downstairs
sister with me is Imani Richard Tyson
Trisha girl I left you on a cliffhanger
a tease of all teasers we'll play it
again now just to remind you in case you
missed it
I watched you yesterday and the day
before I watched you be gaslit by two
ignorant black women I actually felt
quite sorry for you so I want to say
welcome to the club Piers Morgan how
does it feel to be gaslit when claiming
something is racism how's it feel it's
annoying right it's annoying
well Trisha here's your chance to
respond this was of course about our
quite fiery debate in which I got very
exercised about the fact that Megan and
Harry for two years led the world to
believe that the palace had been racist
about the skin color of their baby and
then they decided to turn around and say
actually we never meant that at all
which I thought was deplorable you
defended it and that was iman's verdict
on your defense I was basically getting
gas lit what's your response
um not so much the gas lit bit but um I
guess Iman and I would have to
um agree to disagree I wouldn't call
anybody ignorant just because they don't
agree with my point of view
um and I don't think it's helpful
especially when we're discussing
something like racism
um and you know one black person calling
another person black ignorant because
they don't agree that so that that I
find that I find sad I I'm saddened by
that and and you know so I'm not going
to pick a fight with Imam about that
because I've seen that happen uh on you
know I've worked in the media for 35
years I know how that game's played
um so so that would be my only comment
she's entitled to her view
um you're entitled to your view I'm
entitled to my view but I think it's I
actually think it's quite disgraceful to
label someone ignorant purely because
they don't agree with you so it's not
acceptable to call someone ignorant but
you can call them disgraceful Imam
well no no I said doing it is
disgraceful the same thing you just call
it I'm saying Iman you're just doing
this ignorant
I think it's I just heard you you just
said she was disgraceful so let her
answer she was disgraceful okay Iman
you're a disgrace for calling Trisha
ignorant I think I'm awesome personally
so I just want to throw that out there
secondly I never called you uh ignorant
because you didn't agree with my opinion
I called you ignorant because you have a
lack of knowledge there's a clear
difference and it was never about a view
it's about just understanding facts and
when we talk about unconscious bias
that's based on feeling that is a fact
Trisha so it's not about mean you
disagreeing as two black women I'm going
to call you ignorance in spite of your
color if you have a lack of knowledge
simple as that
oh thank you so much you're welcome well
Trisha come on you've got to answer the
charge it was basically your ignorance
in lack of knowledge of the subject you
were talking about
if somebody decides that I'm ignorant
I'm not going to sit here and try to to
dissuade them otherwise they've quite
clearly made up their minds if Imam
wants to call me ignorant and thinks of
me and ignorant what have you yeah fine
go ahead because she did a lot of damage
that day you did a lot of damage and I
had to come along and fix it just like
Harry did a lot of damage and other
people had to come along and fix it me
Shola kionde we had to come along and
fix your dirty works you know what I
don't have time for people like you when
you come on national TV spewing garbage
and you're right I'll actually add to
your second point I don't want to argue
because I'm a bit more in fact I don't
believe black women should come onto TV
arguing so I'll just leave at that I
called you ignorant because of your lack
of knowledge
that kind of ends there basically I mean
Trisha what I would say as the token
white man in this debate is I would say
this about what happened last week I was
surprised actually that you with all
your experience of broadcasting and
journalism you're a smart person
that even you when you heard Harry
basically gaslighting the World by
saying we never it was the media that
said that this was racism we didn't say
that and then you literally watch back
exactly what they said to Oprah Winfrey
and they were blatantly accusing a
senior member of the royal family of
being racist about their unborn child
skin color I was surprised that you
couldn't find it in yourself
notwithstanding your support for them
but as a black woman to understand the
damage that that did in playing the race
card as strong as it did to Oprah
Winfrey and then expecting two years
later we would all just sit back when
they go we didn't mean it as racism and
we'd all go oh oh that's all right then
after two years
headlines around the world calling the
royal family races because they had
called them races
I have to actually with that agree with
Richard Tice my colleague Richard Tice
in saying that when Richard you were
right in if it hadn't been Oprah Winfrey
if it had been a British interviewer I
think a British interviewer would have
challenged them on that and got them
actually to say the words my whole thing
was that they didn't as as Susanna uh
your old colleague agreed they didn't
actually say the words and the reason
they didn't I don't think is because
they'd actually said the sentence they
probably would have been sued or God
knows what so my whole argument was they
didn't actually say the words
as I said to you last week the key line
to me the key line in that whole thing
with Oprah was when Oprah did actually
follow up with one and said are you
saying that the concern was that if the
baby's skin color was too Brown too dark
that would be a problem and she said yes
basically you may well think that that
assumption that was a direct charge of
racism I I I would have I would have
pushed it further I would actually say I
would have actually asked a question are
you saying that somebody in the royal
family is racist I don't actually look I
agree and I would have done but actually
I don't think I needed to Richard ties
putting aside all the what side you're
on of this debate look there are lots of
people who don't agree with me I get it
but on that I did feel completely
incense for the royal family for two
years they had to put up with this
charge of racism against all of them
because we never got told who it was but
supposedly expressed this concern and
when you watch back that exchange with
Oprah it was unequivocal yeah when you
watched it back she specifically said
that it would be a problem if the baby's
skin color was too dark yes was the
basic answer no one had any doubt and
there hadn't been any doubt all over the
world for two years until Harry's
interview and they won the conflict
series they never corrected it and and
so everyone's left completely gobsmacked
and you're sort of wondering what's
Harry's objective here the agenda has
changed
yeah so the that's the that's the point
so did he find him no one word about
this in the book no no exactly it's as
though he thought I've gone too far here
right I need to I need to somehow find a
way to row back or let's just give a
distraction and go down another route
there's so many inconsistencies in all
of us
I think it was very damaging you know if
I represented a group like black lives
matter for example and I'd be working
really hard to try and drag
people with you know racist
um undertones about them into a world
where they're not racist because you
explain what racism is to have a member
of the royal family and his wife on two
of them on global television
branding the royal family racist and
then basically saying that's not what we
meant I get why that would incense you
it would incense me I thought it was
absolutely disgusting and that's why I
apologies for cutting you earlier I just
had to make this point about the agenda
changing I just want us to look at their
Journey for a moment we watch them
expose their truth we like the their
truth
um you see I've changing right expose
their truth defend themselves and now
they are on stage three which is about
making amends and so therefore each
agenda requires a different approach and
so from another strategic standpoint if
you take off the most damning claim of
them or which is the racism Claim by far
the reason why is because you have to
remember it connects to the royal family
potentially paying reparations and you
don't even want to think about what that
number would potentially but I would
also I would also add the other main
charge which I felt was incredibly
damaging was this allegation direct
allegation that Meghan Markle felt
suicidal and had gone to somebody at the
palace seeking help and had been told
she couldn't get it because it would be
basically damaging for the brand again
not a word of that in the book that's
just disappeared like that never
happened we never got told who that
Palace employee was for all we know that
might they might still be working there
did they say that did they look at a
woman saying I'm suicidal and say you
can't get help I didn't believe it at
the time I don't believe it now not a
word in the book and this is again I
think a form of gaslighting on that
issue so you've got race and mental
health or the two sticks to beat the
royal family with both of them now
shattered in terms of any evidence I
will not defend the indefensible I know
that people like Trisha and many others
try I'm not prepared to do it once I
realize you're a lie or a liar I will
defend what I believe in but once you
have crossed that line you've crossed
that line and that's a really good
example of the contradictions I hate to
point out contradictions I'm a big fan
or was a big fan of both of them but
even the whole therapy thing I mean I
could sit here and defend you know for
very long lengths of time sitting
conversations defending them but the
reality is they've contradicted to
themselves they contradict themselves
when it came to the whole
and they have lied on a global stage
repeatedly and caused enormous damage
and I said this two years ago nothing
has changed my mind in fact if anything
the disingenuousness of the race charge
being removed the mental health stuff
just disappearing and not being
mentioned again has all just confirmed
to me I was right all along I mean it's
been concreted in stone this lying these
inconsistences and you sort of wonder
where does it go from here the only
upside is that Clarkson's done the royal
family a favor yeah and I agree with
that point they have to maintain the
moral High Ground say nothing do nothing
send an invitation but make sure through
the back door they understand they're
not to come